how's it going best the names put my
welcome back to the Lakeview cabin the
spookiest game i have ever spooked let's
see if we can beat the first chapter
alright let's just focus on night
hey I'm naked how's everyone doing I
mean I know naked again what are you
doing it yet no goddamn he's naked don't
don't sniff my butt again no no come on
just let me sniffing a little bit all
right fine Lisa is going Lisa you broke
the radio
you sure never okay what was that I
almost didn't see it what the hell
alright there's max here that means we
can defend ourselves I want her to come
and get the ax horses Bell do
if we just spawn Satan what hey took the
axe no oh god oh god oh god ah my face
my beautiful face
ah drop it drop it drop the bomb Rock
yes that'll show him
that oh god I kill it please nice ah I
got him from freaking the [ __ ] hey how
you doing man I'm a leg
you're they got Lisa I must save Edgar
you're already hard oh there is you look
great oh my god
oh no I failed give me the axe no no no
oh [ __ ] oh good job good dad do
something
Greta ah looks like it's all empty Kunta
that is Korea that is not good yeah make
mine good ich meine as stub plainness
indus button mattnic oh oh you did that
that's nice it's very nice
oh not yet is it yeah
I can't this game oh okay so this time
we're gonna do it and we're gonna do it
right maybe Kunta Kunta oh god oh god I
see it already no Dutch is not good run
count on Ron okay again no no oh god no
good go Jeff go down nine nine peace -
good job ah oh my god ice cut the axe
run again when you go when you go way to
go way to go / - go - go where he go go
tell that is good yeah ah I need him to
come down
oh [ __ ] sacred to die
alright we're gonna do this come on well
well then don't worry I know exactly
what I'm doing okay I'm so prepared this
time you don't need Oh God
so let's ring the bell and you should
come I think I think that's how it works
I'm not entirely sure though yeah yeah I
think we would spawn sat on see if we
can get the bike see if we can get on
the bike one time yeah that's good run
Lisa Lisa is so shocked all right
go Lisa Lisa it's your birthday happy
birthday Lisa Brock condition get him
while he's down gunshot rap no God can
tell you're dead I'm sorry just take him
Gunther um this one no wait uh throat oh
god this is very bad oh god am i I
burned them all yes did we kill him all
my friends are dead but hey buddy Lisa
is fine
Lisa's fine I'm fine hey we did it hey
now I just have to get rid of my friends
DP DP P P P P P P P P P P P you keep oh
we sickness me maybe to be P P DP I'm
naked baby Pappa but a patio we kill
that monster now I'm naked all my
friends are dead hey ed yeah you made it
how's it going rose oh god what was that
I swear I heard something God ah nein
I'm naked oh god it's so [ __ ] dark
ah no ah come on
even my dog we were closed this one that
was progress all right we're set up we
can do it at this time rose I have faith
let's hide this character somewhere
there we go run gotta run
ah there we go here we go hip it go okay
and now it's Lisa yes that's how we do
it oh yeah play so damn nice our jumper
baby
all right racy Hey no [ __ ] me how
oh [ __ ] amok out like a phone oh there's
a gun upstairs how do we get upstairs oh
I can use the axe on that door okay this
game is really interesting I feel like
it's exploration meets horror and humor
come on please work yes
all right now we have a gun let's try
this yeah baby
that's go Melissa
make know it is not dead [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ah ah so close
all right price I'm gonna have to end
that there if you want to check out the
game and help me out figure it out I
leave a link to our description it's in
the pit PI store how about that it's new
it's it's nice supports charities maybe
like you've enjoyed this video but I
really appreciate it have thought a lot
and let me know if you're one more uh if
you like if you want more how about then
I'll see you in the next one I have a
second I want to ride the my nap yeah
baby what's up ah [ __ ] ah oh no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
why did the deed you nut